Dalam bab ini kita akan bagi kerangka
untuk berfikir tentang persekitaran komputer
yang boleh diguna pada laptop kau
dan ditingkat skala sampai ke superkomputer
pada akhir bab ini
kau akan faham konsep asas sumber komputer
dan macam mana ia berkaitan antara satu sama lain
jadi apa tu sumber komputer? senang je
ia adalah komponen yang membentuk sistem komputer
kita ada CPU atau unit pemprosesan pusat
yang laksana kebanyakan arahan, kita ada memori
atau RAM yang simpan data untuk sementara
dan arahan program
dan kita ada GPU atau unit pemprosesan grafik
yang direka untuk rendering grafik
tapi boleh jugak digunakan untuk tugas pengkomputeran tujuan umum
yang perlukan banyak pemprosesan selari
macam simulasi saintifik, analitik data, atau pembelajaran mesin
sumber-sumber ni bekerja sama untuk laksanakan atur cara
dan setiap satunya ada unit ukuran sendiri
contohnya unit CPU diukur dalam bilangan teras
dan kelajuan jam, manakala memori diukur dalam bait
dalam giga, mega, dan terabait
untuk setiap masalah kita
kita perlukan satu set sumber
untuk laksanakannya
penting untuk pertimbangkan keperluan sumber bagi melaksanakannya
dengan cekap — lokasi di mana komponen atur cara dilaksanakan
dan lebar jalur infrastruktur yang menghubungkannya
memainkan peranan penting
dalam menentukan prestasi keseluruhan
contohnya GPU mungkin laju untuk kira bahagian tertentu
dalam atur cara kita, tapi kalau memuatkan atur cara ke memori GPU
ambil masa lebih dari yang kita jimat
mungkin lebih laju guna CPU je — sekarang
jom kita bincang tentang penskalaan sumber klasik
kita ada dua pendekatan: penskalaan menegak
dan penskalaan mendatar. penskalaan menegak melibatkan penambahan
kuasa satu sumber tunggal
macam guna CPU yang lebih laju atau tambah lebih banyak memori
dalam satu nod fizikal
di mana nod adalah unit kluster pengkomputeran yang merangkumi pelbagai
sumber di dalamnya. penskalaan mendatar pula
melibatkan penambahan lebih banyak sumber
macam pelbagai CPU atau GPU
untuk bekerja sama pada satu nod atau banyak nod
kedua-dua pendekatan ada kelebihan tersendiri
dan kelemahan tersendiri, dan pilihan bergantung pada keperluan
kes penggunaan tertentu. sekarang mari kita perkenalkan jenis sumber baru
sumber quantum. sumber quantum memproses maklumat quantum
dengan unit pemprosesan quantum atau QPU. QPU
adalah sistem penuh yang bertanggungjawab
untuk menerima set arahan quantum yang boleh dilaksanakan
atau quantum circuit dan kembalikan
jawapan yang tepat. maknanya
QPU merangkumi satu atau lebih cip quantum
contohnya IBM Quantum heron
serta pelbagai komponen tambahan
dalam peti sejuk pencairan
yang membaluti cip quantum itu
seperti elektronik kawalan penguat quantum
dan komputer klasik yang diperlukan
untuk tugas-tugas seperti menyimpan arahan
dan bentuk gelombang dalam memori, mengumpul keputusan
dan pengekodan pembetulan ralat pada masa hadapan
secara umumnya sumber quantum diukur
dari segi kualiti: skala kesetiaan berlapis
bilangan qubit
dan kelajuan: operasi lapisan circuit per
saat atau CLOPS. hari ini kita akan layani cip quantum
sebagai unit ukuran, sama macam sistem pengurusan sumber
layani GPU — bukan ikut bilangan teras
tapi keseluruhan unit. macam mana pula dengan penskalaan?
macam sumber klasik, penskalaan sumber quantum boleh
jugak dikategorikan kepada menegak
dan mendatar. penskalaan menegak
adalah dengan menambah bilangan qubit setiap chiplet
atau setiap cip
penskalaan mendatar pula adalah dengan menghubungkan cip-cip
menggunakan couplers atau interkoneksi klasik
dengan definisi tu dah jelas
jom kita bincang tentang pengurusan sumber
pengurusan sumber dalam infrastruktur komputer merujuk
kepada proses merancang
mengagih, dan mengawal penggunaan sumber pengkomputeran
seperti CPU, memori, storan
dan lebar jalur rangkaian untuk pastikan
penggunaan sumber yang cekap dan berkesan
kau boleh bayangkan pengurusan sumber
macam permainan Tetris berbilang dimensi di mana blok-blok
tu adalah keperluan kerja kau
di mana setiap dimensi adalah unit sumber. tugas umumnya
adalah untuk muat masuk blok kerja tu ke dalam kiub
semua sumber yang ada. pengurusan sumber
adalah tugas yang sangat mencabar dan kemudahan pengkomputeran berbeza
menggunakan taktik berbeza untuk konfigurasi infrastruktur mereka
mengikut keperluan khusus pengguna mereka
untuk guna konsep yang kita baru belajar, kita akan guna
Slurm. Slurm adalah perisian sumber terbuka
untuk pengurusan sumber
untuk tujuan demonstrasi
saya ada persediaan tempatan dengan tiga nod maya
kita boleh dapatkan maklumat tentang nod komputer tu
dengan jalankan perintah scontrol
kita ada dua partition atau kumpulan nod
normal dan quantum. partition normal terdiri daripada nod
yang hanya ada akses kepada sumber klasik
dan partition quantum pula ada akses kepada sumber quantum
jom kita mula dengan contoh mudah
hello world klasik dengan Slurm
pertama kita perlukan atur cara hello world itu sendiri.
Dan ni adalah atur cara kita yang cuma cetak hello
world.
Sekarang kita perlu beritahu pengurus sumber
sumber apa yang kita perlukan untuk laksanakan atur cara ni
macam yang kita bincang, Slurm bagi cara untuk tentukan
semua metadata untuk kerja melalui
skrip shell
dengan beberapa anotasi khusus Slurm
anotasi ni bagi kau peluang tentukan keperluan sumber
parameter penjadualan dan lain-lain.
Kita boleh semak skrip penghantaran kita
dan di sini ada spesifikasi partition
berapa banyak nod yang kita perlukan, berapa tugas per nod yang kita nak
laksanakan, berapa banyak CPU per tugas yang akan digunakan
dan skrip mana yang kita nak jalankan
dan ni adalah atur cara hello world kita.
Untuk hantar kerja kita untuk dilaksanakan, kita hanya perlu jalankan
satu perintah iaitu sbatch
dan bagi skrip kita sebagai argumen
kita boleh semak barisan pelaksanaan
dan tengok atur cara hello world kita sedang berjalan
pada partition normal di nod c satu
bila kerja dah selesai kita boleh semak hasilnya
tengok fail output.
Dan tu je.
Kita juga berminat nak guna sumber quantum
jadi jom kita cipta atur cara hello world Qiskit yang mudah.
Ni adalah atur cara Qiskit kita yang ada semua
langkah yang perlu untuk penciptaan circuit
pengoptimuman, pelaksanaan, dan pasca-pemprosesan.
Dan ni semua konsep pengaturcaraan yang kita bincang
tentang quantum circuit, transpiler
dan primitif Qiskit
sekarang kita perlu cipta skrip penghantaran
macam sebelum ni, tapi di sini kita tentukan
keperluan sumber quantum
memandangkan kita dah tentukan sumber
dan partition dalam kluster
sumber quantum apa yang ada
primitif Qiskit akan guna
sumber yang diperuntukkan untuk laksanakan kerja quantum.
Sekarang kita perlu jalankan atur cara kita.
Dan bila kerja dah siap, kita boleh semak hasilnya.
Dan ni adalah nilai jangkaan kita.
Dan tu je untuk pengurusan sumber
dalam bahagian seterusnya kita akan bincang
tentang model pengaturcaraan